this video I just want to show you
another way of making a PCA plot and
working with the platform so again what
we did is we process the data here under
transcriptomics RNA seek we got the
table of expression we maybe did a
normalized quantile normalization under
utilities and now what we can do is go
under unsupervised analysis and what you
will see here is that you have these two
options PCA and PCA draw okay so let's
go ahead and add some files what I'll do
is I will take some files that I have
you might have different files so let's
go ahead and take okay let's do
unsupervised okay so we have these genes
right here okay let's just take a look
that we've got the right table so we've
got some samples here we've got a bunch
of gene IDs so let's just take this all
right now we've got continued start will
choose PCA draw now if you remember in
the previous exercise what we did with
PCA is we generated the full PC table we
had a bunch of different PCs and we
selected only two so we can do three or
we can just even change it to two we
don't want to scale Center transpose yes
let's go further
do end okay and I will just do elia PCA
okay run pipeline and now that the
pipeline is running let me just tell you
a little bit of what we're doing so if
you remember we went in the previous
example we went under utilities and we
selected this PCA right here now this
PCA does exactly the same thing and the
only thing that the other pipeline
actually does is adds another option to
do an R script to run an R script and
generate the scatter plot within the
pipe
okay so let's go under my pipelines you
can see that this is processing now
remember that if you have something like
this that says prepared that means that
you have not started the pipeline you
did not press on one pipeline I didn't
do it because I was demonstrating and so
I didn't really want to waste the
resources and run the pipeline but
sometimes you will have this option to
run pipeline here you can see this
already processing that means it's
working
all right so how do we get the results
let's give it another minute
all right and now you can see that it is
done let's go to output files and the
first thing that we want to look at is
this file right here PCA plots okay and
now look at what we have here we have
all of these different groups that we
can already visually see because all of
these are sample names and they're
colored differently and so we just see
them colored by sample name because we
of course didn't have a label and so
what you can see here is just each dot
represents a sample and this PCA plot
helps us visually see that there may be
three groups in this dataset
okay now let's do this let's go back to
areas of analysis unsupervised analysis
we will upload a different file marked
and now you can see that for each one of
these samples we also have an annotation
what group they belong to let's do this
let's open the file and then it will
upload press Continue start ok pc ain't
wrong okay yes and save now I will do
the pca and run pipeline so what I want
to see now is how the annotation will
come up on the plot and now you can see
again it's started let me go back to my
pipelines you know
alright let's just give it a moment okay
so now you can see that my pipeline has
finished
let's go download out the files and now
let's go to PC Platz
okay now let's see what we have okay
well now we have the colors based on the
different groups so what is interesting
here and what's interesting here is that
we have this is going to be the cloth
the luminol
this is going to be our basil this is
gonna be normal like and this is going
to be cloudy look okay so now you'll
have this very clear separation between
groups and now what you can also see is
I didn't change it from two to three so
I kept it one two and three so we have
two combinations bc2 and pc1 & pc2 and
pc one and third combination PC PC 3 and
PC 2 so those are the different options
that we have now not only that we you
can also see here is you get the actual
text file so the same table that you saw
before let's see what it looks like okay
so now if we open this file in Excel
again we will see the different pcs and
you will get an R pack once in the park
back ok
in the art pack you actually have the
full script now you can modify the
script in R and get it to do whatever
you want so you can add labels and you
can add all kinds of other information
that we don't have and this is something
that we're going to cover in a different
video alright thanks a lot